britney spears is getting applause from
fans and fellow celebrities for her
passionate plea to a los angeles
judge for 13 years the pop star's life
has been controlled
by a legal conservatorship created at
her father's request
after a mental health crisis in a rare
public statement about the case spears
told the judge yesterday
i truly believe this conservatorship is
abusive
and i just want my life back lilia
luciano was at the courthouse for that
hearing lilia good morning to you
good morning tony spears said her
conservators have been
exploiting her and it was time for the
public to hear what she has to say
for the next roughly 20 minutes the
singer spoke sometimes very quickly
revealing many details that have been
carefully guarded for many years
[Applause]
in 2018 hot off a las vegas residency
britney spears hit the road
for her piece of me tour
[Music]
the show's raked in more than 50 million
dollars but spears says she was forced
to perform
against her will wednesday the pop star
told a judge her management threatened
to sue her
it was scary and with a conservatorship
i couldn't even get my own attorney she
said
so out of fear i went ahead and i did
the tour
spears went on to slam her father and
others for controlling everything
from her money and medical care to whom
she gets to see
telling the judge ma'am they should be
in jail
she claimed that her father took
pleasure in his power saying
he loved the control to hurt his own
daughter
one hundred thousand percent i'm totally
fine
i'm extremely happy spears went on to
say that social media posts like this
one
were lies i'm not happy i can't sleep
i'm so angry i cry every day
how unusual was britney statement in
your opinions
i think the statement itself from
britney spears was
highly unusual because it was so
anguish it was a plea
of frustration of pain
the mother of two said she wants to
marry her current boyfriend
and have another baby but can't because
of a contraceptive device
this so-called team won't let me go to
the doctor to take it out
she said because they don't want me to
have any more children
what do we want outside of the
courthouse
dozens of fans from the free brittany
movement rallied
it's really good to be here and to hear
brittany speak and like basically
validate everything that i've been
suspecting other people's been
suspecting
and basically dispel a rumor that it's
not a conspiracy
spears ended her statement with an
emotional plea
i feel ganged up on and i feel bullied
and i feel left out and alone
and i'm tired of feeling alone an
attorney for spears's father
said his client is sorry to see his
daughter in so much pain
and that he loves and misses her very
much spears asked for the
conservatorship to end
without a mental evaluation the judge
thanked the star for her courageous
words
and said she would need a formal
petition filed with the court
before taking any action